Marjorie Taylor green of Georgia is one
of the very few members of Congress who
cares at all she has led a delegation to
the jail where many of these defendants
are now being held she joins us now with
the report on which she saw
congresswoman thank you so much for
coming out for doing this so what was
your impression of the conditions that
these protesters are being held in
well I think what we all saw was a big
cover-up you see I've been in the been
in that jail before and I know what it
looks like I was there back in late uh
2021 when myself along with Louis Gomer
were the only ones to go into the jail
and see the conditions that the
pre-trial January 6 defendants were
being in being held in and it was so
horrific that we wrote a report called
unusually cruel that still on my
congressional website today well we
finally were allowed to go back in after
demanding another visit from the mayor's
office for over a year we went in with
the oversight committee and what we
found is they had scrubbed the jail
clean cleaned up all the mold and
freshly painted the entire area so that
it looked a lot better well I got to
tell you Tucker it fooled the Democrats
Robert Garcia and Jasmine Crockett that
came along with us because they praised
the jail after we left and their in
their press conferences and praised the
warden but I guess since they're so new
in Congress they didn't know the history
that this jail has and how many
Democrats in Washington don't like the
jail either the fact that anybody is
being held without even a trial yet over
two years later is shocking to the
conscience to the Democrats in the
delegation seem stunned by that it
doesn't seem like an American thing to
do
no they didn't care at all as a matter
of fact they criticized us for talking
with the pre-trial January 6 defendants
and being friendly with them but you
know what we would have talked to the
other inmates and defendants that were
in the jail in other areas if they had
given us a chance you see it was
interesting the director and all of the
employees at the jail they wouldn't let
us talk to anyone else in the jail only
the pre-trial January 6 defendants which
I found very disturbing because I want
oversight of the entire jail but other
things that I found that really bothered
me and I think it should bother everyone
and we as Republicans have to do
something about it is the medical
director in the jail showed off and
bragged about all of her medical
services and treatments that they can
provide in the jail but when we talked
to the pre-trial January 6 defendants
they told us they were receiving no
medical treatments for problems and
health problems that they have even one
man in there with non-hodg chickens
lymphoma he has cancer and he doesn't
get any treatment there it's really an
atrocy I don't think you need to be
Republican or a Democrat to care about
civil liberties and human rights and
really appreciate your calling attention
to this consistently over the years
Margie Taylor green thank you yeah thank
you
thank you subscribe to the fox
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight